weder die szenen hier das
aggressionspotenzial es wird immer höher
wir haben es gerade noch einmal gehört
inwiefern bekommen dass die politiker
gerade in der debatte überhaupt mit was
da nur wenige meter wenige hundert meter
vor ihren türen passiert also das sehen
die politiker erst mehrere smartphones
weiter
die die gerade keinen sitzungsdienst
haben wegen corona ist eine begrenzte
anzahl von abgeordneten überhaupt im
saal
die sehen es dann halt auch die normalen
fernsehen und jetzt gerade ist peter bis
tron ein abgeordneter tschechischer
herkunft der asd aufgestanden und hat
quasi das spiel weiter gespielt dass die
hier den ganzen tag spielt er hat erst
jetzt quasi in einer nebenbemerkung in
einem zwischen einwurf gesagt dass
einige abgeordnete afd jetzt leider
nicht teilnehmen können weil sie in der
demonstration sind und wir schreiben uns
jetzt gerade als obwohl sie friedlich
sind obwohl sie sich hingesetzt haben
werden jetzt die wasserwerfer
aufgefahren also hht spielt pingpong
aussehen sagen nach draußen von draußen
rein in den saal
hier sind gäste unterwegs die andere
abgeordnete anderer parteien hier hat
bedrängt haben das ist perfide spiel
dass die die hier heute ab sie gleich
werden sie hinter mir auch noch eine
stellungnahme abgeben
also das ist inszeniert das programm
graf ihr die afg spielt mit diesen
ganzen kräften und jetzt auch quasi aus
dem bundestag herausgestreckt man an
einer legende
aber die normalen abgeordneten kriegen
als kind das mit die wissen auch darum
und mal ganz im ernst es ist alltag in
deutschland demonstration man hält sich
nicht an die auflagen hält sich nicht an
die regeln
dann kommt die auflösung wird der
auflösung nicht folge geleistet dann
kommt die androhung wir werden dann
räumen
dann wird dem immer noch nicht folge
geleistet und dann wird geräumt das ist
auch wieder deutschen demonstration so
dass wird durchgesetzt endlich auch mal
in berlin endlich auch mal bei einer
krone demo endlich auch mal bei think
werden kann
das ist normales polizei handwerk und
das gehört sich so und so wird euch da
draußen dann quasi auch für demokratie
mit verteidigt mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren